it fixes the chemistry laureate in
economics sciences your excellence
members of the Academy ladies and
gentlemen those who have the ability to
observe but nobody else is able to see
in light of the world and bring
knowledge to the benefit of mankind as
expressed by author Schopenhauer
talent hits the target no one else can
hit Venus hits the target
no one else can see the role of science
is to question what is regarded as the
truth to uncover hidden phenomena to see
the possibilities which are a skill to
the narrow mind as seen Rene Magritte's
LeClair Williams to think outside the
box as we would say today the passionate
observer equipped with imagination and
creativity leads us forward to a better
world this requires hard work and
occasionally courage since it happens
that those who pave the way are met by
distrust or even resistance today the
Church does not band the scientists like
the ones did with Galileo but the world
is not even prepared to accept
scientific achievements and even the
scientific community may need time to
recognize and accept but at least slowly
new parodies are accepted is suddenly a
new interpretation of an image appears
then it is not possible to unsee to
understand the world we live in we need
to understand the nature or the the
invisible building blocks that matter
medical the tiny neutrino has captured
the fascination of not only the
scientist but even a writer like John
Updike who made poetry of the particle
assumed to have no mass it reads
neutrinos they are very small they have
no charge and have no mass and do not
interact at all the earth is just a
silly ball to them through which they
simply pass like dust mates down a
drafty hole or filters through a sheet
of glass
now the poem has been ruined because we
know that they have a tiny mass but
instead we have gained a more profound
knowledge of the world we live in our
DNA
although giant creatures compared to the
priests a neutrino are travelling
tirelessly from generation to generation
seemingly resistant to all attacks until
the waked eye and cover their nature
detected their fertility but also their
ability to heal we live in a dark world
with terrorists refugees and where many
people still live in poverty but you
inside and unconventional ideas help to
find ways to improve the living
conditions and promote welfare for those
who are exposed to poverty we need to
trust in science because only knowledge
can make the world better Alfred Nobel
recognized the importance of science and
those uncover what has been hidden who
explained our mere existence who improve
the quality of our lives who opened
doors for
your findings this week is the big
celebration of science and today we are
going to listen to some of those who
have increased our knowledge and made a
difference to the way we think I will
now ask professor Liu Li to introduce
the Nobel Prize in Physics
dear larette's
ladies and gentlemen its pleasure for me
to introduce the Nobel Prize in Physics
we are talking about neutrinos neutrinos
are very interesting and fascinating
properties they are very abundant
they're almost as abundant as photons
there are many billions of neutrinos in
this room at this moment they travel
almost at the speed of light neutrinos
are very elusive particle they interact
we are the weak interaction with a very
short range that means that they travel
in this room and they are not affected
they travel through earth without being
absorb or anything they just go through
neutrinos have three flavors they can be
electron million or tau and they can
change flavor and this is this year's
Nobel Prize discovery they oscillate we
are talking about neutrino oscillation
neutrinos have a mass and this is
because of this year's price discovery
they were assumed to be without mass now
we know that they have a mass very small
mass but since there are so many of them
this is a large mass and this is
changing our understanding of the
universe the discovery was made in two
scientific collaborations one in Japan
with as prominent scientist professor
Takayuki carita called super-kamiokande
they were looking at neutrinos
atmospheric neutrinos created when
cosmic radiation interact with the
molecules of the atmosphere the second
collaboration is Canada should bury
neutrino Observatory
collaboration led by Professor Arthur
McDonald it's now time for me to
introduce the first Nobel laureate
professor Takaaki kajita he was born in
March 1959 at higashi matsushima Japan
he studied first at Saitama University
and then at the University in Tokyo when
he got his PhD in 1986 and since 1988 he
has been at the Institute for cosmic
radiation research 9999 he became
professor at the University of Tokyo and
is director of the Institute for cosmic
ray research so professor can cheetah
please
good morning well first of all I'd like
to thank the kind very kind introduction
and also um I want to mention that this
is really the greatest honor for me to
give this lecture today today and I'm
going to discuss discovery of atomic
neutrinos but the outline of this talk
is showing here first I have an
introduction that is the introduction of
the kamiokande experiment that was the
starting point of my research then I
want to discuss the authorship neutrino
deficit then the discovery of discovery
of neutrino serations recent results and
the future they are summarized and
finally I want to mention the
acknowledgment now introduction well in
the late 1970s new theories that unify
strong weak and electromagnetic forces
were proposed these theories predicted
that protons and neutrons namely
nucleons should decay with the lifetime
of approximately ten to twenty eight to
tend to saturate 39-year society - sorry
this is long enough to think about the
real effect however
these are short enough to observe the
proton decays therefore several proton
decay experiments began in early 1980s
and one of them was the Cameo candy
experiment
notice of Jesus okay this is the photo
of the Kamioka experiment it is a three
kiloton watering of detector and the
fiducial mass for the analysis of
neutrino events or protein decays was
about one curtains and a drug to tell
you the basics of this experiment if a
charge relativistic charge per charge
particle propagate in water then they
check of light and these photons of
light are detected by photon detectors
that are placed on the wall of the
detector and you can see these dots
actually photo detectors and I want to
mention that initially come you can't
was rather small experiment well this
was the I would say construction team in
spring of 1983 and you can see here here
is Professor Koshiba who is the Nobel
laureate in physics in year 2002 and
also you can see professor tadka
professor Tiffany and also you can see
students maybe two three meters behind
professor Kosovo okay
there's already introduction of
neutrinos therefore for this stage I'm I
could be shot but let me repeat on it we
knows fundamental particles like
electrons and quarks
they have no electric charge and they
have three types or three flavors
electron neutrinos muon you
gina-san tau neutrinos and they are
produced in the earliest places such as
the Earth's atmosphere or center of the
Sun and they can easily penetrate
through the earth or maybe the even the
Sun so if a neutrinos neutrino is
produced here they can easily propagate
through the detector ideas unfortunately
also through the detector and go to the
space but they can however interact with
matter very rarely if neutral
interaction occurs Noomi produces a new
a new e produces an electron and also I
want to mention that in the very
successful Standard Model of particle
physics neutrinos are assumed to be to
have no mass however physicists have
been asking neutrinos really have no
mass now I want to move on to the
AutoStick neutrino deficit well I want
to explain a little bit causing creep at
who's entering in the atoms here
interact with the nucleus then these
interactions typically produce ions and
then these ponds decay to me wants to
electrons and in this decay chain to
muon neutrinos and one electron
neutrinos are produced and these are
observed in underground detectors now I
want to mention a little bit my work in
early days and I got my PhD in March
1986 based on the search for proton
decay well of course I didn't find any
proton decay
but anyway I felt that the analysis
software was not good enough to select
the signal that is spot on the case from
the background that is the auto Sigma T
no interactions most efficiently
therefore the Sooners I submitted my
thesis I began to work to improve the
software and one of them was the
analysis software to identify the
particle type for multi recovering
events namely I wanted to know if say
each tank offering
its on each chain covering in the
marketing event is produced by an
electron renewal for example the season
of observing event in suit in Castle
kamiokande
and you can see three challenge
offerings here and I wanted to know if
they are produced by a mule one electron
anyway the new software was ready and
was applied to single chain core
ingredients which were the easiest
events to analyze so it natural to start
from the easier thing then the neutrino
flavor was study for the AutoStick
neutrino events these are the typical
events observed in kamiokande these this
is a typical event pattern for electron
neutrino interaction this is the typical
event button for muon neutrino
interaction and we immediately found
that the result was strange the number
muon neutrino event was much fewer than
expected
at first I thought that I made some
serious mistake in order to know where I
make mistake I decided to scan the vents
and immediately I realized that the
analysis of software was right however I
was not optimistic yet I thought that
it's very likely that there are there
were some mistakes somewhere in the
simulation data reduction and event
reconstruction so we that means mostly
touch design and myself started various
studies to find mistakes in delay 1986
well actually after more than one year
of studies we concluded that Numa
deficit cannot be due to any major
problem in the data analysis nor the
simulation and therefore kamiokande
decided to Turkish this result and
history in this paper in this
publication we reported these numbers
the number of electron neutrino events
of that was 93
while the predicted number was eighty
eight point five so basically they agree
however for the mule neutrino events the
number of observed events in the data
was 85 while the prediction was 144 it's
clear that there is a deficit in the
numiri vents and in paper we concluded
that we are unable to explain the data
the result of systematic detector
effects
or uncertainties in the atomic Newton
fluxes some accounted for physics such
as neutrinos relations might explain the
data
what up this stays this is still might
however well I I got very much excited
and I want to mention my personal memory
well I was mostly excited with the
possibility of neutrino oscillations
with large mixing angle namely new mill
seems to oscillate maximally to the
other neutrino type and this maximal
oscillation was not expected therefore I
got the excited and this gave me the
strong motivation to continue the study
now I mentioned neutrino oscillations so
I want to explain a little bit about
neutrinos reactions this was also
mentioned already at the beginning
therefore I would not be very precise
but anyway if neutrinos have masses
neutrino change their flavor or type
from one flavor to the other
for example oscillations could occur
between new neutrinos antineutrinos
and if a muon neutrino is produced here
then if they propagate long distances
they disappear and if they propagate
even further they be appear and if
propagate further disappear again they
appear again and if new neutrinos
disappear
the term neutrinos appear so this is the
neutrino oscillation and one important
thing is if the neutrino mass is smaller
the oscillation length that is well for
this figure may be this distance
gets longer so in order to study small
neutrino masses you have to study
neutrinos that service long distances
and also I want to mention that these
are theoretically predicted by these
people maki Nakagawa circuit and
Pontecorvo now so far I have discussed
here kamiokande result but there are
other there was other experiment called
onion B that was another large water
tank of detector and they also reported
the deficit of neo neutrino events so
that is in current II however well I
thought we thought that the simple
deficit of muon neutrino event is not
really enough to conclude to be neutrino
situations we wanted to have more
positive evidence for oscillations then
well actually the physics is simple if
neutrinos are produced in the odd part
of year of a detector then the travel
length for neutrinos are shorter enough
therefore they have no time to oscillate
however if a neutrino is produced in the
other side of the earth then they need
to travel long distances before eating
to the detector so they may oscillate
therefore which we conclude that we
should observe the deficit up of apart
going muon neutrinos and in fact
kamiokande try to see this effect and
well we studied but we see some
however it was clear that Camille Khan
was not big enough to to be conclusive
therefore it's Korea that we needed much
larger detector and therefore we needed
super-kamiokande now I want to move on
to the neutrino oscillation discovery
well of course the discovery was made by
the super-kamiokande experiment it is a
50 cotton water tank of detector and the
fiducial mass that is used for the
oscillation studies is twenty two point
five kilo tones which is more than
twenty times larger than the fiducial
mass of kamiokande and this is a big
experiment and big international
collaboration we have about 120
collaborators from these countries I
said this is an international
collaboration and in fact this is an
international cooperation from the
beginning of the construction and this
photo shows the initial discussion about
the super-kamiokande collaboration
between Japan and the United United
States and here you can see professor
Tosca who was the spokesperson of the
super-kamiokande and also you can see
various key people in this photo and
this photo was taken at the Institute
for cosmic ray research probably in 1991
now this is the photo of the
super-kamiokande detector well this was
taken January 2 1996 and you can see the
pure water was filled up to this level
and you can realize how big the detector
is if you notice three people on the
lava board anyway the super-kamiokande
vector was constructed and started the
data taking in April 1996 and since then
silver come you can has been observing
lot of lot of auto technician events
this is the typical single chunk of ring
we been observed in super-kamiokande in
addition we have these events and you
can clearly see two chancof rings in the
event furthermore we have this kind of
event this is the neutrino interactions
occurring in the detector but the
charged particle in this case muon
penetrates through the inner detector
and you can in fact see the signal in
the outer detector in addition we have
yet another sample that is the upward
going muons here the neutrino interact
in the lock below the detector and only
a move on is observed here you can see a
mule enter from this point and it dated
at this point so these new ones come
from below and penetrate to the top and
I want to mention that all these events
are used in the analysis and each event
have a very different event topology
therefore we need to work Kohi
country and collaborative work of many
people who are more exactly many young
people by essential to the discovery
anyway after two years from the
beginning of the super-kamiokande
explainin we conclude that the data give
the evidence for neutrino situations and
this is thus right used in neutrino
conference in 1998 and this is the most
important plot in that presentation well
let me explain a little bit this is the
genus angle distribution and cosine
theta equal 1 means neutrinos coming
from above cosine theta equal minus 1
miss means neutrinos are coming from
below and you see that for neutrinos
coming from above the observed data
which are shown by the black dot in
agreement with the prediction which is
shown by these squares however if we
look at the neutrinos coming from the
other side of the earth we clearly see
the deficit and from this result
together with the other data
super-kamiokande concluded that the
observed this angle dependent deficit
this one and the other supporting data
gave evidence for neutrino oscillations
well so far I discussed the result from
super-kamiokande
at that time there were other atomic
neutrino experiments the macro in Italy
and Sudan to in United States these
experiments observed auto segment in us
and confirmed neutrino serrations
therefore the neutrino oscillation was
quickly accepted by the Latino community
now in the remaining time I want to
discuss a little bit about the results
of recent results in the future well I
said essentially based on this
distribution we concluded that neutrinos
oscillate well it was very nice that to
say that approximately half of the
long-term you neutrinos disappear
however we think that we want to really
confirm neutrino oscillations and if we
look at the prediction so
oscillation probability as a function of
log of distance should be like this so
we really wanted to observe this depth
in order to confirm the early neutrinos
object and therefore well
super-kamiokande tried out a special
analysis and in fact of shaft
deep well the dip is not as deep as this
date but anyway this is the data the the
depths of the deep deep is just
consistent with the prediction if we
consider the detector resolution so if
we are very happy that the deep was seen
at this position and this really tells
us that neutrinos really oscillate
well we discussed the neutrino session
discovery in 1998 super-kamiokande is
still taking data and objects to compare
the Moschino data in 1998 and the data
so far accumulated it in a conference in
1998 we used 531 events in order to
produce this probe and if we do the same
now then the number of events used in
this protease 5485 so we had ten times
larger data sample and we are continuing
detailed studies of neutrino serrations
and here at this point and I want to
mention two main results well first of
all heaviest neutrino mass is
approximately 10 million times smaller
than the electron mass which is the
agenda lightest particle except for
neutrinos so you can realize that
neutrinos mass is really really really
tiny in addition we found that nume
oscillate maximally to new towels which
is to me really surprising and we really
want to understand why now
I want to mention a little bit about
their overall history of development of
neutrino oscillation experiments as I
said the re noony noony deficit was
concluded to the neutrinos Christians
and this discovery motivated the
accelerator based neutrino oscillation
experiments to further study oscillation
effect and the these studies together
idea updated meet eternity no data
requires the full sleeve revelation
effect and well this effect was biggest
effect was already observed by this
experiment however the story is not
complete yet the neutrino community is
trying to understand further which could
be the most important parameter to be
observed so I could say I would say that
our understanding of neutrino
oscillations have been proven trump
tremendously however we still have to
understand neutrinos more now I will
summarize an unexpected mutant deficit
in the atomic neutrino flux was observed
in Kamioka in 1988 subsequently of the
10 years in 1998 super-kamiokande
discovered neutrino serrations which
shows that neutrinos have mass I feel
that I have been extremely lucky because
I have been involved in the excitement
of this discovery from the beginning the
discovery of non-dual neutrino masses
open a window to study physics beyond
the standard model of elementary
particle physics probably that of the
grounding
of elementary particle interactions
there are still many things to be
observed in neutrinos and further
studies of neutrinos might give us
fundamental information for the
understanding of the nature such as the
origin of the matter in the universe
well before concluding I would like to
acknowledge people who contributed to
the discovery first of all I want to
thank creators of cameo Canyon
super-kamiokande experiments in
particular director Zhang Masato Yoshii
Bonjour Tosca for their continuing
support of and encouragement of my
research throughout my career
Adkins worked with me on the gnosis of
eternity nose in super-kamiokande for
many years Masato Takata and Kenji conic
worked with me in the Kamioka analysis
yeowch Tosca yo Ichiro Suzuki and
masayuki Nakata have been reading the
super-kamiokande experiment hands over
and Jim stone had been reading the u.s.
effort of super-kamiokande kendo
Nakamura and octo Suzuki played very
important roles in the early stage of
the super-kamiokande experiment and last
and maybe the most important hard work
by young collaborators of
super-kamiokande was essential for the
discovery and I I also want to thank
Morihiro Honda for the neutrino flux
calculation and finally super-kamiokande
acknowledges next do ye and Kamioka
mining and smelting company well thank
you very much for your attention
we professor capita for a very nice
lecture and now we turn to neutrinos
from the Sun and it's a pleasure for me
to introduce Professor Arthur McDonald
he was born in in Sydney Nova Scotia
Canada in in 1943 he studied at
Dalhousie University in Nova Scotia and
then at the California Institute of
Technology in the US where he became
doctor in 1969 he worked at the chalk
river nuclear laboratories and in 1982
and then it became professor first at
Princeton University and then later at
Queen's University kingston canada and
is presently director of the Sudbury
neutrino Observatory scientific
collaboration so please professor
McDonough
thank you this is a great honor for me
and my colleagues too and we would like
to thank the Royal Swedish Academy of
Sciences and the Nobel foundation for
this tremendous honor it's also an honor
to share this prize with Professor
cajeta and the members of the
super-kamiokande collaboration for the
beautiful work that you just saw so I'm
going to tell a slightly different story
a story that was happening in parallel
with the one you just heard and one
which was attempting to address
neutrinos had come from the Sun a case
where it had been a possibility that the
explanation for what had come to be
known as the solar neutrino problem was
due to flavor change for neutrinos in
this case electron neutrinos produced in
the core of the Sun and so I'm going to
tell you about how that was done with
the Sudbury neutrino Observatory which
is actually represented in reality here
this is a picture taken looking up from
the bottom of the sphere surrounded by
light sensors in much the same way that
light sensors were used in the
super-kamiokande experiment so neutrinos
you've heard about their properties they
can penetrate through almost anything
they're a wonderful way to study what's
happening directly in the core of the
Sun eight minutes ago they travel almost
at the speed of light they're produced
prolifically by the fusion reactions
that are powering the Sun and they reach
us here on earth and they can even
penetrate through to our detectors which
in our case were situated two kilometers
underground the story of the Sun is a
long one and this phrase that we stand
on the shoulders of giants is something
that is very true in this case
hans bethe and William Fowler who was
the head of the laboratory in which I
studied at Caltech in 1969 have
developed the understanding of how the
nuclear reactions power the Sun and Ray
Davis and John Bacall were pioneers in
the study of the neutrino oscillatory
noise from the Sun Ray Davis with his
chlorine based detector who observed
that the number of neutrinos that he
measured were about three times smaller
than what was calculated by very
sophisticated calculations that John
Bacall and collaborators carried out
Bruno Pontecorvo was mentioned earlier
and along with the Japanese
collaborators who put forward the what
we these these days refer to as the EM
NSP approach to understanding the three
flavor oscillations at the time that the
deficit was observed by Ray Davis
Pontecorvo & grebe off suggested that
perhaps the explanation for why too few
neutrinos were being observed was that
electron neutrinos had been changing
into muon neutrinos in transit from the
core of the Sun at that point of course
the knowledge of three neutrino types
was was not present and that has was
expanded later to the thought that it
was the possibility of oscillation into
either of the other two types the actual
reactions that are occurring in the Sun
that produce the neutrinos you can see
the neutrinos circled in red here are as
shown here this is what the energy
release in the process is shown here are
what produces the power in the Sun in
1984 the start of the Sno collaboration
occurred because herb chen asked whether
it's conceivable to obtain enough heavy
water from canada's reserves to perhaps
do an experiment in canada using that
heavy water there was a wonderful
correspondence with george youin who's
here with us today who had been looking
for the opportunity to do underground
science in Canada and had identified an
ideal location which was provided to us
by the International nickel company in
Sudbury Ontario a very deep location and
the idea that herb put forward was that
if you studied some of these are the
highest or close to the highest energy
neutrinos produced if you had enough
heavy water you could conceivably make a
measurement in which you could not only
observe the type of neutrinos that were
being produced in the core of the Sun
but also observe the sum of all other
neutrino types and so a direct
comparison of those two things would
tell you whether the doctor or neutrinos
were changing into the other types
without recourse to calculations of how
many were being produced in the core of
the Sun and so in 1984 a collaboration
came together
this shows the collaboration picture at
chalk river in 1986 and it also at the
bottom shows a paper that was published
at this at that time putting the concept
forward the spokespersons at that point
were herb Chen for the United States
George Ewan for Canada they were joined
about a year later when the UK joined
the experiment as led by Dave Sinclair
and we started attempting to develop
this experiment unfortunately about six
months after this picture was taken
herb chen passed away from leukemia much
too early an age and we we still miss
him and regard him as a substantial
origin of this
experimental collaboration after herb
passed away I took over as the u.s.
spokesperson for the project and in 1989
became the director of the project as we
were all working very hard to put
together this experiment in the meantime
we had been joined by more groups in the
United States and and Britain and we had
a more substantial collaboration at the
time that we were funded in 1990 so how
did we detect neutrinos from the Sun
well those billions that are streaming
out from the from the Sun require a
large amount of material in order to
obtain enough interactions to get
statistical accuracy on the numbers that
are in fact being observed both in the
category of electron neutrinos and other
types and so we needed a big detector
and we also needed where are the
properties of this rather unique
material heavy water about one in six
6,400 molecules of ordinary water that
you drink have an extra Neutron in the
nucleus in the hydrogen nucleus making
it deuterium or d2o
rather than h2o and we were able to
borrow a thousand tonnes of this
material and that's what we used as the
basis for our detector if you have that
material then there are some specific
reactions that you can observe in all
cases using the same current cough
radiation as was described to you
earlier for the super-kamiokande
experiment and using light sensors
surrounding this tank of heavy water the
first one is very specific to electron
neutrinos we call it the charged current
reaction and I will refer to CC later on
as a monadic for this particular
reaction sensitive only two electron
neutrinos in this case a deuterium of
course as a neutron and a proton in it
as you can see here one of those
neutrons has changed into a
and a fast-moving electron that produces
trunk off light in your detector the
second reaction which is a unique one
for deuterium is one in which any
neutrino type with equal sensitivity
electron Muir Tao can break deuterium
apart giving you a free Neutron we used
three different techniques to detect
those neutrons in different phases of
the project and that particular case is
only sensitive to well it's sensitive
all neutrino types and so if you compare
these two then you're able to tell if
the number of electron neutrinos is the
same as the total in which case nothing
will have happened but as we eventually
observed we only saw one third as many
electron neutrinos as the total
demonstrating that neutrinos had changed
their type you have to be very careful
when you're trying to do this
measurement because it is possible for
radioactivity particularly gamma rays to
break deuterium apart producing a free
Neutron and so we had to control
radioactivity extremely carefully in
order to be sure that we were not seeing
a false signal from that radioactivity
and therefore we went to great lengths
to control radioactivity in our
experiment
there is another reaction in which the
neutrinos strike electrons and this is
in fact something that super-kamiokande
also used to look at solar neutrinos it
has predominantly a sensitivity to
electron neutrinos but it has a small
sensitivity also to all neutrino types
and in fact before our our full result
using the first two reactions we
combined our data with data from
super-kamiokande and had a preliminary
indication that neutrinos from the Sun
were in fact oscillating the three
techniques were used for detecting the
neutrons are a little complicated
technically but basically in the first
phase of the project we simply looked at
a particular gamma ray that's produced
when that Neutron is captured by the by
the deuterium in the
factor that gamma-ray is distinctive we
later put several tons of ordinary table
salt in the heavy water and that
increased the efficiency for detecting
that Neutron by a significant amount and
also created a situation where we could
by looking at the distribution of the
event on our photos sensors we could
tell the difference between this case
where there were many gamma rays being
emitted and therefore it was quite
uniform or writes a tropic compared to
that very specific trunk off ring for
the case where we're dealing with just
electron neutrinos and then finally we
put 400 meters of ultra low
radioactivity proportional counters that
had helium-3 in them and detected
neutrons directly and that I'll show you
a picture later was the third phase of
the experiment with a separate
measurement entirely of those neutrons
so what did this detector look like well
first of all it was about the size of a
10-story building it was 2 kilometers
underground in a very active nickel mine
one of incas most productive mines and
it continues to be to this day owned by
the valet company we had that thousand
tons of heavy water that was about 300
million dollars worth loaned to us for
$1 for 10 years that's pretty good
leverage in any market and Canadian
government agency that loaned it to us
was really one of our tremendous
benefactors along with inc o in
providing us with this with this
wonderful underground location it was
housed in a transparent sphere which is
12 meters in diameter and about five
centimeters thick tremendous
construction project to build this and
also to build the remainder of the light
sensor structure that looked in at the
heavy water in the central region
because we were restricted to have
everything in a mine cage which was 3
meters by 3 meters by 4 meters and so
this detector had to be very modular and
then reconstructed
on site so we looked in with these
lights this light sensor array at the
burst of light that I just described to
you and we were very careful in terms of
radioactivity we surrounded everything
other than the heavy water sphere with
ultra pure light water and that was
housed in a watertight and radon gas
tight liner so we had graded
radioactivity you start with uranium and
thorium which is the main elements those
are the main elements that create
radioactive problems for us they're
about a part in a million in the rock
and in the middle it was less than about
a part in 10 to the 15 of those elements
so one radioactive decay per day per ton
of water so the people that developed
the radioactivity control systems led by
Dave Sinclair did a tremendous job to
make this project a success the location
is as I say 2 kilometers underground
it's down in a very active nickel mine
we traveled in this shaft and and
transported things to our site here a
very stable underground site which we
have used for for many years I guess I
should have had the Eiffel Tower on
there as the as the icon for this
particular presentation in the United
States I usually say that it's the
entire State Building that I should have
as the icon I have that on good
authority because one of my sons at age
7 when we were at Princeton went to the
New York City for a for a visit and came
back and told us that he had seen the
entire state building so we proceeded
from there with this construction
project you'll see that everyone in this
picture is wearing lint-free clothing
the cleanliness aspect of this project
was tremendous well we had a million
pieces
the time we were finished we had less
mine dust on that entire structure then
you could pile on your thumbnail less
than a gram overall and that was
essential for us to be able to do this
experiment we estimated over 70,000
showers and changes of clothing for
people in order to maintain that
cleanliness throughout the project the
water systems were a tremendous success
everything was very clean you can see
the example of the floors here when my
mother visited shortly after we got that
in place she said looks pretty clean
there so I figured that was probably a
pretty good affirmative statement with
respect to how well we were doing you
can see here that we were posed with a
substantial problem when Stephen Hawking
visited but Inco was very good and
designed a special railcar to have him
come underground a very inspirational
figure this is the data that we obtained
from the first phase of the experiment
in which we were capturing the neutrons
in heavy water producing a six million
six point two five million electron volt
gamma ray and this is a distribution
I'll show you in a moment how we
calibrated that this is a distribution
that represented all neutrino types this
is what we expected from the charge
current reaction that was only electron
neutrinos and we did a test of this
which for which the results are shown in
the next transparency what we tested for
is a hypothesis that neutrinos were not
changing their type and what we found in
fact that what agreed with the data was
something that had less than a five
Sigma possibility of or less than one
chance in ten million that in fact the
trainer's were not changing their type
from this data and the most consistent
result had a very good agreement between
all of the neutrinos after the change of
type had taken place
and the total number calculated by the
solar model John Bacall and his group
and only one-third of the neutrinos were
actually still electron neutrinos
two-thirds of them had changed to the
other two type two types
when this result came out John Bacall
who'd worked for so many years on this
was quoted as saying that he felt like
the DNA evidence for absolving him of
many years of questioning had finally
come in and so he was in fact a very
important part of this whole story of
solar neutrinos to show you how we were
able to know that those shapes were in
fact the way they would be we had a
source of 6.13 rather than 6.2 5 MeV
gamma rays that we were able to move
around within our detector with this
rather remarkable manipulation system
created by another one of our colleagues
and which enabled us to put a variety of
different radioactive sources and other
sources of gamma rays in particular this
one at almost any location in the
detector and this is what we expected
from the reaction that looked like that
were created by electron neutrinos and
these are calibration data that we
obtained with the other calibration
sources this is what we obtained with a
neutron source as well so we had the
ability to know what shapes we would
expect and we could do fitting to see
what it implied in terms of the physics
we also did a tremendous amount of work
to be sure that that question of whether
or not the numbers of gamma rays were
great enough to have produced free
neutrons simply from radioactivity that
they were low enough throughout the
experiment we had set a goal of how much
radioactivity we would have from radon
gas and they in the water from radium
and from which is the daughter of
thorium and another radium daughter of
uranium and you can see that essentially
starting around the beginning of the
project and except for a few periods
where we didn't use the data we had met
our goals throughout the project this is
making measurements with external
techniques on the water system that we
were using to put to purify the water
and we were also able to look at the
data inside the detector itself and we
had several techniques for
distinguishing between a technique in
terms of the isotropy of the events for
distinguishing between uranium and
thorium and we could set limits on that
basis as well we were able to ensure
that the numbers of events that are
arose from gamma rays breaking apart
deuterium were more than a factor of
three smaller than the actual signal and
we knew what that number was to better
than 30% giving us an overall 10 percent
uncertainty in the initial phases and
better later this is the actual data
that we obtained that I showed you
earlier and this is where after we put
salt in you can see that what happened
was that the charge current result
essentially stayed the same and the
result from the neutrons capturing in
the salt went up substantially and
what's interesting in this slide is that
this is what we predicted this is what
was simulated in 1987 by another one of
my colleagues is here today and you can
see that the relationship between these
parts of the data as you can see here
and here and what we predicted for the
radiation background wall which goes up
strongly in these two plots as well in
the same location is essentially the
same in other words that's what we said
in 1987 would be possible if we could
actually do it and the data in later
years shows that it was actually done
another way of showing the results is to
plot the sensitivity of the reactions to
muon and tau neutrinos combined and
electron neutrinos on this axis this is
the plot associated with the all
neutrino sensitivity this is the plot
associated with just electron neutrino
in that reaction you can see where they
cross is our result you can also see
that the results shown by the black line
here from doing the same plot for the
super-kamiokande
data and then with less accuracy our own
data from the electron scattering
reaction is in very good agreement with
it you can see the uncertainty in all
neutrino types is shown in this this
number here and you can see the
comparison at about well nearly 5 with
the predictions with 5.8 plus or minus 1
point 3 from McCall and from Silva and
Turk she has another very substantial
worker in that calculational area that
the agreement with solar models is
really very good and by the time we got
to the salt phase we had more than 7
standard deviations clear indication
that the electron neutrinos compared to
all neutrino types is about 1/3 we then
moved on to a phase in which we
installed 400 meters worth of very low
background Neutron detectors great
success by the Neutron detector team led
by Hamish Robertson but as an indication
of how you do go through some
difficulties in these experiments and
have to modify things mid-range you can
see what the what this the submarine
used to install them ended up looking
like this is what it looked like when we
first designed it I mean if you were
going to build a submarine what color
would you pick it of course yellow
submarine except that particular yellow
paint was very radioactive and we had to
scrub it all off and have a very mundane
submarine in order to do our work so if
you include the great work that had been
done by other measurements including
cameo Canada and super Kenya Canada on
solar neutrinos what you see is that in
1980 now well here is the first result
starting in 1968 of Ray Davis where the
threshold for using
Laurene is at this point and so
everything in terms of the different
reactions as a function of energy
everything above this threshold
contributes to the results in 1989
kamiokande and super-kamiokande started
to provide results that were
increasingly accurate for the higher
energy neutrinos in 1992 the to gallium
experiments age and Galax /gn oh they
were sensitive to the PP neutrinos and
in all cases these were either
exclusively or predominantly sensitive
to electron neutrinos and so we still
had a puzzle in 2001 we started
presenting our results in 2000 before we
presented our results this is the sort
of thing that you would see for the
results as a function of energy
different different reactions in the Sun
contributing to the results and the
theory being shown up here as a as a 1
and you can see there were deficits in
all of the cases by the time we had
finished the three phases of the of the
project we had shown for all three
phases that the total number of
neutrinos was in very good agreement
with solar model theory and that the
electron neutrinos were actually for
boronate being observed at this sort of
level and it is this difference that we
use for that preliminary result I
mentioned with super-kamiokande so as
was mentioned neutrino oscillations are
a case where flavor change can occur in
an oscillatory fashion in quantum
mechanics that is usually represented as
the so-called flavor states where which
is the the state that's created when a
neutrino is produced either by an
electron reaction or a muon reaction or
a tower reaction that they are a
superposition of states of mass 1 2 & &
3 and you can see what is now thought to
be an indication of what those
components are
then as the neutrino travels through
space the mass fractions change and then
when you make a measurement again to ask
how much does this look like an electron
at we know a muon neutrino or a town or
Treena or in other words in quantum
mechanics what's the probability that
you would observe one of those three
types the fractions have changed and so
what you find in fact is that for muon
neutrinos you have that changing over
the distance of the of the earth and in
the case of the Sun you also have a
change it turns out that if you combine
all of those experiments that I was
mentioning and others that have come
later to measure solar neutrinos you
find that there's another phenomenon
that has occurred in the Sun and
phenomenon that was put forward by
mikheyev and Smirnoff working with
previous papers by a wolfenstein in
which it is stated to be possible that
if there is a significant interaction
between the electron neutrinos as they
pass through the Sun with the electrons
the dense sea of electrons in the Sun
you could have a transition which would
be such that as it appears to be
occurring such that the electron
neutrinos get put into a pure mass to
state and stay in that state as they
travel from the Sun to the earth and
then end up in your detector showing up
roughly one one-third electron neutrinos
and two-thirds the other types that's a
representation of that mass to state in
addition to that what we determine with
these oscillation effects is the
difference in mass between the neutrinos
and we also determine this parameter for
the mixing which we refer to as theta
1/2
besides that we were able to determine
because of that electron interaction
that mass 2 is actually greater than
mass 1 that's something that's referred
to as the hierarchy and for the case of
mass 3 relative to the rest it's still
an open question that may be resolved we
hope by some of these many experiments
that Professor Gadget
outlined for the future I'm gonna talk
about a couple of other types of
experiments that we're going to be
pursuing for understanding neutrino
properties and also dark matter
particles in the future we now know that
neutrinos have too low a mass to be the
particles that may seem to make up the
dark matter in our universe five times
as frequent in our galaxy as the
particles that make us up and so we're
looking for other particles similar to
neutrinos but heavier referred to as
dark matter we've been very fortunate
that we've been able to expand the
laboratory and the vicinity of the snow
detector in Sudbury to create a new area
which has new experimental opportunities
we're also in the process of converting
the snow detector to a new detector
referred to as snow plus and so what you
see now is experiments in the case of
snow plus that will study something
called neutrino let's double beta decay
as well as further studies of solar
neutrinos and neutrinos from the earth
there are a number of experiments that
are studying dark matter and one that is
studying supernovae as will the snow
Plus experiment the list of physics that
one is attempting to do with such
experiments in the case of neutrino
let's double beta decay we are
converting the snow experiment to a snow
plus a so-called experiment putting an
organic liquid that gives us a hundred
times as much light output having
returned the heavy water and by
dissolving in that tellurium compound we
can use tellurium as a potential for a
potential measurement of rare
radioactivity half-life not quite as
long as proton decay but a greater than
10 to the 25th years or so so you've got
to have a lot more than 10 to the 25
nuclei in order to make a measurement of
that but we think with two tonnes will
a good sensitivity if this rare process
called neutrinos double beta decay
occurs it means that neutrinos are their
own antiparticles and if so then it's
also sensitive to the absolute mass
which we would like to be able to
combine with the differences we've
measured to give the masses of all the
active neutrino types known and we have
the halo detector which reuses the snow
helium-3 detectors to along with lead as
a measurement of supernovae recycling is
a very big topic these days and we're
doing it as much as we possibly can in
these experiments there are also new
experiments in which we're attempting to
observe these dark matter particles
which are similar in their properties of
penetration and difficulty of detection
to neutrinos but which are significantly
more massive and there are a number of
experiments listed here which are taking
place in snow lab now I've emphasized
snow lab because that's where we are
working but there actually are many
laboratories around the world that are
doing similar experiments to this and
we're very optimistic that with the
progress that has been made in recent
years and and the excitement that has
been generated in this field that we
will have a much more complete
understanding of our universe for
example there are theories that suggest
that in fact neutrinos play a strong
role in the conversion of antimatter to
matter shortly after the Big Bang we we
have a very matter dominated universe
but it used to be roughly half and half
after these were created from pure
energy in the Big Bang and so that decay
process may be something that arises
from from neutrino processes and some
combination of what's being measured
with the accelerator experiments and
possibility of understanding whether
they are their own antiparticles will be
significant in attempting to understand
those theories at some of the highest
energies that we can imagine these are
our sponsors
and to whom we are very grateful it
emphasizes again that although this
experiment took place in Canada it was a
truly international experiment from the
very beginning as you saw with herb Chen
being one of the founders and Dave
Sinclair joining with the UK very soon
thereafter
you see the list of institutions that
participated in the project and here you
see the 262 authors you can see that
there are 262 author's although you may
not be able to read every name perhaps
when this is put on the web you can you
can do that and also 11 who have passed
away since we started this project I
personally am tremendously grateful to
this collaboration for all of the
efforts that they've made over the years
and to all of the spouses of the people
in this collaboration who are
represented here today as well so thank
you to everyone
we thank you professor McDonald for this
wonderful talk and I would like to ask
both laureates to come on stage and I
think